it is time to watch new rock star eric
the king of us his easter egg breakdown
for an episode that is filled with
easter eggs that greatly flew over our
heads and i don't care how divisive this
episode seems to be it was a blasty
blast all right
i'll leave it at that
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
what if episode seven what if thor were
an only child and rex midgard and dances
on ashes and steals zemo's moves without
inviting him this whole party episode
was packed with cameos and references to
the marvel films so i'm gonna break it
down frame by frame for everything you
might have missed so we opened in the
new mexico desert the same opening shot
of the first thor film interesting how
we don't see the watcher in the stars
here many other episodes opening shots
of the sky embed uwatu among the stars
but not here for as we will see this
supposedly omnipresent watcher does have
some blind spots jane foster's computer
shows the same van allen radiation belts
around the globe that eric celvik's
computer showed in the movie selvig is
not with them here though so this must
be a different outing one thankfully
without kenneth branagh's random tilted
angles defend it jon hey dutch angles
need some respect
it's the most visually off the walls
marvel movie just in terms of camera
angles alone way to defend it
confidently john well i love dutch
angles man and i had your definitely
think natalie portman returns as jane
along with everyone aside from brie
larson the warriors three actors and
rene russo as friga but like the doctor
strange episode which i believe was a
prelude to multiverse of madness this
cast could have been lured into this
episode as a prelude to thor love and
thunder jane reports
the director of shield because if my
data is corrected believe an alien
invasion is imminent and two years ago
the same anomaly struck star alpha
icarus and the entire star dimmed and
then poof disintegrated jane already
knows what shield is here and she jumps
to the conclusion of it being an alien
invasion but back in the thor film she
had never heard of shield foster i'm
agent coulson with shields is that
supposed to mean something to me shield
whatever they are so this version of
jane might have discovered previous
evidence of extraterrestrial light that
got her on shield's radar sooner i
honestly think it was just a save time
nah as an oversight they forgot we're
already doing like an alternate version
of the first thor movie i feel like they
just got to save some time you know how
we know how it is it's a 30 minute
episode i think that's just what it is
but maybe she mentions the star alpha
icarus explosion that was two years
prior which we later learned was one of
thor's past ragers alpha star now that
was an excellent party did you really
destroy that planet no no it was more of
a meteor anyway not a planet and it was
burning apart so we just kind of helped
it along and so no one got hurt no no of
course not even the baby goat gary got
home safely
eventually icarus was the figure from
greek mythology who flew too close to
the sun so that his wax wings melted and
he burned and died in the ocean similar
to the alpha star icarus burning meteor
that thor laughs off here but thor in a
way faces his own icarus-like hubris
trying to coast above it all but comes
crashing down to reality in the closing
moments we never get a firm answer as to
what exactly went down on alpha star or
what thor meant by that goat getting to
safety eventually but maybe serger
helped them burn it faster and the whole
experience is actually super traumatic
for all of its people and its goats
their star chart shows constellations
including ursa minor which was mentioned
by jane in the film as being missing
signaling an astronomical realignment
that linked earth with asgard look what
do you see
stars yeah but not our stars see this is
the star alignment for our quadrant this
time of year and unless ursa minor
decided to take a day off
these are someone else's constellations
but here ursa minor is visible meaning
thor's arrival wasn't the result of
odin's banishment but thor's chosen
party destination while odin was in
odin's sleep the biocross overshadows i
love your memory mr boss i love your
memory we're too late darcy of course
referencing caroline's creepy line and
poltergeist
they land on the vegas strip in front of
a casino that looks like the bellagio
but the bellagio isn't beside the luxor
and the excalibur like this casino is
here and that's because all these
casinos were slightly altered visually
because there's a copyright law that
requires a license be to recreate these
landmarks and animation
this same elvis later marries darcy and
howard the duck and even later there is
a scroll elvis meaning this elvis might
have been one of those earthbound
skrulls the whole time a reminder that
many among our society are scrolls we
got a secret invasion baby all right
paul from heavy spoilers i'm sorry if
you were mad at me for stealing your
breakdown point and putting it in this
new rockstars reaction i'm gonna do it
anyway buddy so he had a point that was
saying how he thinks that that elvis
might have actually been in reference to
kurt russell like an alternate version
of him to a certain extent especially
because kurt russell has played like
young elvis i believe i forgot what it
was and then he even did like a elvis
impersonator-ish kind of character for 3
000 miles to graceland i don't know i
just like where paul went with it and i
wanted to throw it in here it's good
cause eric had a completely different
one go back and watch kurt russell's
very first movie john i think john
carpenter even made that uh big uh elvis
movie
cool it was so great cool he's gonna
stay in the video
there's also a guy with a pineapple
shirt which might be a nod to take away
titi's pineapple romper at comic con
2017. they kick off the party as what to
observe
more than battles one are lost it's
relationships that truly define a hero
the people who shaped them their stories
as he looks down at the city all those
lit streets makes it look like for a
second he's watching them through a
broken pane of glass reminiscent of the
barrier that he moved to the other side
of when he didn't help strange supreme
and he turns away from all of this
toward the stars but missing what's
going on down below just another example
of how he doesn't always have his eye on
the ball then a slideshow shows thor and
loki's relationship including young loki
playing a trick on thor using the casket
of ancient winters to freeze him odin
holding baby loki as he does in the film
except instead of crying this cute baby
loki smiles this maybe being the true
nexus point because odin would realize
that this child doesn't need his
asgardian warmth it's also interesting
how loki later shows up as a frost giant
when he was supposed to be the runt of
his family so essentially this loki
variant was born as a truer sturdier
frost giant also notice here how they
already cover odin's eye with an eye
patch whereas in the movie it had just
been ripped out in the back oh yeah
of her fellow witches like the choir who
accompanied loki's play in ragnarok but
it's interesting here they're clearly
just trying to make them fall asleep
faster so they can have some wine time
also thor sits bedside totally
uninterested which is exactly where loki
was sitting in the film because thor is
kind of the jerk of the story and odin's
vault they passed the infinity gauntlet
reminding us of how in the first thor
film there was that prop infinity
gauntlet added to the background with
all six stones already in it that was
the first arrangement later marvel of
course retconned that gauntlet as fake
but that was a right-handed gauntlet
this one is the same left-handed
gauntlet with the correct stone
placement that thanos is simple as an
infinity war now yes the blue space
stone should still be inside the
tesseract at this point the timeline the
reality stone should still be hidden
with the ether the gauntlet itself
wasn't forged by e3 until years later
etc etc but i think the idea is that
marvel put a new fake gauntlet in the
vault the way that what if has retconned
a lot of phase one appearances of people
like rhodey and bruce banner they're
also retconning the appearance of that
phase one fake infinity gauntlet but
wait i mean
all right
uh
i get so confused in the timeline to
talk here because are we dealing with a
very exceptionally different timeline
with some of these although like maybe
that was a real gauntlet that they had
maybe in this version of the timeline
somebody amassed all the affinity stones
got the gauntlet and this all took place
before thor traveled yeah yeah i mean as
eric voss pointed out himself natalie
portman already knew about shield
so maybe this is the everything happened
earlier verse yeah yeah i think that's a
pretty likely thing i mean like he
rockets here and all this stuff all
these all these cosmic people are here
in this one episode
it's a lot of different timelines that
are kind of here in one episode yeah
they're all kind of hodge podge together
thor drains and smashes the mug just as
he does at the diner in the thor film
another
wolfstag parties with a couple familiar
faces including a ravager and a woman
with this elaborate face paint and hair
we actually saw this kind of design on
various partiers on sakhar and ragnarok
there's this hooded mask figure we saw
people like this milling around sakaar
damn
[Music]
from everyone and a member of the
sovereign from guardians vol 2. thor hug
scourge from ragnarok thunderhog
yeah have a drink it never runs out you
try to drink it all but you can't
because it's magic he's recalling doctor
strange's magically refilling beer in
ragnarok the ships that beam down are
mostly ones that we've seen in the
collector's vault in episode two but
were originally seen in the grand
master's garage in ragnarok including
that one with the circular window with
the wings that pulled up and then the
simple cube-shaped one there's also a
few asgardian viking boats that we saw
as part of loki's fleet in episode three
and some pre-warships like the dark
aster thor uses scrolls to exhibit his
narcissism and as jane notices them he
does that sexy hair toss that he did in
episode three darcy expected there to be
lasers and flying cows maybe referencing
the destroy all humans game series and
then
unless like a hottie mcscotty beach
buddy ken old school abercrombie catalog
of course i would say e.t and scotty
from star trek i gotta say you know
there's something about the way thor is
in here that sort of reminds me of like
a prince charming out of like the shrek
universe that's what i mean one of those
bad dream reality of what prince
charming ought to be where it's like oh
he's super dashing and buff but oh man
this is kind of a slob he's kind of dumb
he's not all there ah no like you
exactly like me
oh normally you
go on for a lot longer all right let's
go no i'm just gonna yes
they use first contact as a euphemism
referencing the 1996 star trek film you
can make first contact with i don't know
that guy he looks like a loser
big talk coming the duck i know that guy
the duck was actually talking to a
blonde when we saw him partying on
catraxia in guardians volume 2. thor
whip hands over to the grand master at
topaz from ragnarok topaz what do i
always say i love cake i love how tobaz
is eating a whole slice of cake with her
hand and she's carrying that staff that
she and the grandmaster used to melt his
cousin carlo jane only knows thor by his
connection to norse mythology as in thor
the norse god of thunder i don't know
anything about horse gods but i don't
know how to bring the thunder actually
one of thor's successors
with a horse face as jane asked
i love this drunk off-screen height man
in this episode anomaly that preceded it
happened too much tonight or too little
hey thunderboy
off-screen drunkenness when thor reminds
fandral or waking up next to a baby goat
i named him gary yeah you did the party
grandmaster
in ragnarok now the music we hear is
actually a remixed version of the
grandmaster's birthday theme from that
movie
[Music]
topaz stands behind him just lightly
bobbing her hand and then of course thor
does the most dance move nebula shows up
at the crafts table getting korg to blow
on her dice mama needs a brand new eye
referring to the one thanos probably
pulled out of her after she lost
her sister drax and valkyrie joined lady
sip at the bar thori and jane get
matching tattoos she gets a mjolnir
magic one he gets a microscope science
one a reference to his line in the movie
your ancestors called it magic and you
call it science
well i come from a place where they're
one in the same thing but i love how
while jane's skin is still pink and raw
and irritated thor's toughest nail skin
is artists
oh as an asgardian the needle should be
able to puncture his skin so maybe it's
just a deacon they wake up hungover seen
in the hangover there's wild animals in
the hotel room vanderl snugging with
some possums and rocket sleeps in the
sink but remember rocket is a character
voiced by bradley cooper who also woke
up similar to this hey
mirror behind rocket someone wrote v was
here maybe for valkyrie who has seen
partying with them in this episode but
it might also be bull stag and those
hearts could have been drawn by lady
sith because they wake up next to each
other maybe they don't oh that's right
how hell yeah
guys guys look there's a cute little
rabbit in the sink rabbit is correct and
clearly the smartest among you brock
rumlow comes in with maria hill now
acting director of shield since fury got
incapacitated hey because this might be
your party but this isn't your best
friend before someone gets hurt
yes
is sean penn's character from fast times
of richmond high another nickname after
like tony stark is called thor point
break and lebowski hill's helicarrier
hovers over vegas and it's numbered 67
fury's helicarrian avengers was numbered
64. and coulson returns the party
atmosphere seems to be spreading
canada mongolia even pennsylvania dutch
country based on those mongolians we met
in loki these folks must love the party
hill uses nick fury's last resort
captain marvel pager from infinity war
and captain marvel okay that part had me
a little bit puzzled how much does maria
hill have on nick fury and the
information because after the events of
captain marvel where he got the beeper i
thought that was just kind of a
secretive thing between the two of them
that like nick fury had it just on hand
enough for only him to know i wasn't
actually expecting maria hill to have
access to that device or even be made
aware of that device well like
everything in this universe something
happened way before all this to where
that is just a totally different thing
maybe that morning he's like if anything
happens to me after this party you take
this beeper you'll know what to do yes i
mean if anybody might know i guess it
would be her because he always kept it
on him it seemed mm-hmm yeah or in his
jeep
it's a lot to remember he's got a lot of
boss then in paris thor takes a selfie
with some sovereigns including their
leader aisha loki appears where's that
son of the witch poor odin son yes now a
huge jack frost giant like his father
lauffy and he has a big horned crown of
ice again it is interesting to see him
grow like this when he's supposed to be
the runt but i suppose it was just
odin's asgardian magic that caused loki
to take on those human flesh tones in
his size and of course he calls thor son
of a witch because frigga is a witch as
captain marvel arrives france is just
labeled in big letters on the continent
you can see belgium in the netherlands
beyond it's just a really silly
animation choice that they use
throughout the fight something that you
would see in looney tunes carol calls
him white you get it his hairband and
thor responds his name is four with a t
and an r and an o
and an h but not in that order yeah it
sounds right to me because tro in this
episode is very much a bro thor's off
screen returns there's a mid-guardian
word for women like you
party pooper
there i said
the party pooper line is not what makes
it funny it's the laugh and it's the
part where he goes there i said it that
makes it funny yeah well because you
think he's gonna say something else what
i love though is how he pointed out that
it is like something out of looney tunes
this episode itself to be had that vibe
just just like hit me captain marvel
fighting each other feels like road
runner-esque oh yeah when they land in
that desert that's like a desert that's
specifically ripped out of a roadrunner
cartoon that's what i mean man you can't
see it in that lens haters and not
everyone can
serious a dour yeah yeah when i don't
have the popular opinion i'm like guys
just respect my opinion that's a
different opinion but then when you
disagree with me i go let me tell you
what's wrong with you idiot you yeah
hypocrisy the key to doing youtube
captain marvel dodges mjolnir but it
hammerings back to hitter in the back of
the head later in the fight carol learns
to dodge it as it comes from behind
making her more like that badass she was
an endgame when thor summoned
stormbreaker past her head thor
dickishly dominos stonehenge eric
selvig's favorite place to streak
similar to how clark griswold does this
in european vacation they slug it out
it's awesome to watch carol beams his
head and he levitates mjolnir from one
hand
some great electronic rock music plays
evoking the music composed for ragnarok
by mark mother's ball thor anchors her
with mjolnir and the other partiers
include a guy dressed in a celestial
inspired costume like those we saw in
sakaar oh wrinkle mouth on the right is
one of those sakar gladiators as well as
that weird helmet dude on the left and
then yeah a few scrolls point in mock
carol as the pooper kind of cold
considering she saved a lot of their
fellow refugees 16 years earlier hold on
a second you were able to tell that this
was that from a super blurry picture
maybe eric has one of those police grade
like enhance this what the hell are you
i need to steal one of eric's eyes maria
hill references carol's flirting goose
your cat could devour whole army you've
got a cat what's his name goose oh top
gun you're maverick is your ego writing
checks that your skills can't cash no
calling back the line from top gun son
your ego is writing checks your body
can't cash and she says that she thought
carol would be a dude captain
referencing the fact that captain marvel
was a male superhero originally they
discussed hitting thor with a nuke level
blast it's not a bad idea actually the
mojave desert could withstand the hit
the mojave desert is where shield built
project pegasus which in avengers the
tesseract portal caused to implode in a
huge crater just shows how they designed
the space in case something like that
might happen sirter clancy brown
returned to voice him flirts with the
statue of liberty burns her arm off and
then the frost giants deface mount
rushmore using the casket of ancient
winters the party moves on to the sydney
harbor bridge where korg dances with a
baby pacifier alongside more familiar
faces mantis some asgardian soldiers one
of those yellow sex spots from contraxia
more scrolls ravagers and sovereign
valkyrie and meat shows up and then that
strainer helmet dude is another runaway
gladiator from sakhar
filling her in but only between sips of
chardonnay it's thor
he's in trouble he's on earth
carol knocks thor to siberia where hill
and rumlow prep to nuke them both but
forget intervenes what are you doing
here you must be using a lot of dark
magic just to check in on me yeah dark
magic or dark energy is what the
asgardians use to transport themselves
without the bipros as loki mentioned
avengers with the bifrost gone how much
dark energy did the your father have to
muster to conjure you here and as
heimdall said his dying breath
[Music]
loki apparently played to use the saint
louis arch as a giant slingshot and then
to the left of yondu with the mask
that's another sikhar gladiator from
ragnarok who are you and there's people
but everyone bounces let's go topaz we
shall ride like the wind please ladies
we're keeping the scoot scooters nebula
refers to thanos um i think i hear my
dad calling good luck but thor uses
millionaire to scare everyone into
helping him out you can see the disc on
the top shows the same norse runes on
mjolnir from the films and these
translate to he who wields this hammer
commands the lightning and the storm
they thick stonehenge and the st louis
arch the power blackout the statue of
liberty mount rushmore and the ferris
wheel and even though it wasn't their
fault the leaning tower pisa it's
actually kind of similar to how evil
superman fixes this one doesn't need
it
scrubs throw rocks off of a wall and
judging from the white or rocking around
the washington monument so thor tries to
fool friga but mjolnir is covered in
underwear and mardi gras beads and
graffiti looks like it reads crazy night
and drifting and hot tea and then
there's a picture of someone bearded
this might be thor from another time
when he had that awesome beard thor
schedules a date with jane and the
watcher tries to wrap things up together
they lived happily ever after
but he blinks i know it's just a
character blinking but it does cause the
gleam of his eyes to vanish briefly i
just think it's another example of how
this watcher's more human features make
him less of an eternally seeing godly
presence because if one can blink one
can miss things even for the briefest
moments which might be why as he
realizes this is actually twist ending
he says wait what
huh yeah normally the watcher is the one
to tell us when a dark ending is coming
but this time he is caught off guard as
much as we are i think this sets up the
watcher to finally intervene on a
multiversal threat that he worries might
even affect his own existence that
threat an army of ultron centuries
coming from a portal led by ultravision
whoa
hold up dale
that
was a classic voss catch
because
whoa when you first said he blinks
my mind goes
so
and then you explain it and i go holy
crap he's got a great point here it's
canon it's a plot point
when he blinks and the light goes away
and yeah he was startled by the whole
thing with uh ultron showing up when
he's always kind of narrator yeah and
there's something here where he feels
like involved in the actual events like
the way the events are unfolding before
him that are taking him by surprise
whoa
that blink said so much more
wait what who are you ultra vision armed
with all six infinity stones but since
the mind stone is in vision's head it is
the green time stone that is in his
chest the time stone being the
penultimate stone that thanos got before
the mind stone i love how all of these
sentries are eliminated red which in age
of ultron was how we could tell which
one drone contained ultron's
consciousness at any given moment but
this tells us that this ultron can exist
as all of them simultaneously of course
using his stones this ultron must have
completed his original plan to transfer
his consciousness into the synthazoid
body with vibranium infused tissue and
the mind stone which of course the
avengers converted into vision using
jarvis ai but in this universe tony
stark would not yet have the mind stone
in order to launch his ultron ai and
create that problem to begin with so
this ultravision must come from another
universe one where he might have used
that divine knowledge from the mind
stone to locate all the other stones
before thanos could and then went on to
conquer that reality and then move from
reality to reality to conquer the
multiverse
it also means we are learning a new
function of the six infinity stones
combined not just the ability to erase
half of all life or all of life but the
ability to transcend realities as a
nexus being which also poses some
terrifying implications for zombie
thanos who also acquired all six stones
we know from trailers that party thor
will join a team of black widow captain
carter strange supreme and others as
they fight ultron sentries and there was
a clip of party thor telling strange
zombies great idea making me wonder if
the watcher's next move will be to
assemble these misfit toys into a team
to play these two nexus threats to the
multiverse ones that he did not see
coming until now against each other you
can support new rock stars by checking
out our great merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com like this awesome
what it should get one of these you can
write
after show follow me on instagram and
twitter at ea bots follow and subscribe
to new rockstars thanks for watching bye
i have a feeling that the final episode
is gonna make all the episodes well
worth it it's gonna be one of those or
even the ones you don't really like are
gonna become better in appreciation from
like all bad boys work did you get to
these final episodes
i have a strong indicator i like where
your head's at might be a little too
bloated though if you have ultrons and
zombie thanos i feel like ultron's is
the way to go ultron is the way to go
yeah because it's the only one that
startled the watcher yeah he's going to
be like guys i messed up whoa
i was doing my shift my security guard
shift took a coffee break got back to
the room and the prisoner was gone you
guys got this right
i don't know what to do i just watch
things guys subscribe to new rockstars
if you haven't done so already because
they are the bomb hit that like button
or the dislike button depending on how
you feel about john specifically at hey
we'll catch you guys soon
you